I don't think I've ever touched your
foot in my hand before one time he
recently fractured his foot and wanted a
foot massage and I was very hesitant so
I massaged his hand instead oh man this
can be really hard I definitely don't
think this is Steve's foot it's a little
sticky and I feel like Steve also runs
so he probably has more on the bottom of
his foot so I definitely don't think
this is Steve's foot this one's
definitely hairier now I'm thinking that
the other one might have been closer to
his foot also feels like this guy uses
lotion I'm pretty sure he doesn't use
lotion I think this might be Steve's
foot actually I don't know this but
seems huge for me now I'm starting to
think that maybe I was wrong and maybe
the first foot with Steve foot I'm gonna
go with number one Oh turn right now oh
definitely not Steve I do not even know
who this kid is hi I'm Jevon oh um I
really hope I'm right on this one I'm
getting cats number three Oh oh man so I
failed lotion up is this so I guess he
eases it I don't use lotion
okay you've made the first guest wrong
fine I was sure that I would be a close
second but uh not even close in fact I'm
actually so relieved that it feels like
you wash your feet
I don't lotion up the feet I know if you
want me to start I guess I could but
again you hate feet we don't spend all
day the first time I've touched your
feet that's three
five years either way probably won't
ever touch your feet again
so Oh would you want touch my hand
no touch her